le voyage en avion une envie dépassé je
vais parler avec vous durant mes
quelques minutes 2 comment penser du
voyage et surtout du voyage en avion
quand nous sommes aussi confrontés par
les défis du changement climatique et de
l'urgence de réagir
mais d'abord revenons à l'humain et à
ses aspirations et envies
de tous les temps voyager été source
d'inspiration comme le dit si bien
gabriel garcia marquez dans son poème
billard à
voyager c'est partir de chez soi c'est
quitter ses amis s'est essayé de voler
voler vers d'autres horizons parcourir
les routes c'est tenter de changer
voyager c'est s'habiller de folie c'est
de dire je m'en fiche c'est vouloir
rentrer rentrée ans se voit savourant
les petites choses déguster un verre ses
désirs et recommencer
dans notre monde interconnecté et
globale je porte la conviction que
voyager est aussi une liberté qui doit
être accessible à tout le monde et à
toutes les classes sociales cette
liberté doit aussi permettre à chacun
d'articuler son désir de voyager comme
il entend
voyager vers des horizons lointains
était très restreint jusqu'à la deuxième
moitié du siècle passé soit par sa durée
soit par son prix
l'aviation a amené dans les dernières
décennies du xxème siècle un degré de
liberté pour le voyage très important et
a commencé à permettre des voyages qu on
ne s'imaginait pas vu le temps de voyage
avec d'autres moyens de transport
pour illustrer ceci laissez-moi vous
partager quelques expériences
personnelles au début des années 80 j'ai
eu envie une envie importante sortir de
ma suisse natale de mon carcan familial
et de l'école qui se limitent
essentiellement à la région de berne la
seule manière de faire ceci était
d'investir plusieurs semaines et de
voyager en train avec un abonnement
intérêt il à travers l'europe ce que
j'ai fait mais l'investissement en temps
et surtout entendant les trains étaient
considérables et finalement nous avons
finalement raccourci nos plans de voyage
pour nous poser à un endroit
quelques années plus tard pour visiter
une amie chère qui passait son été sur
la ferme de sa famille en or du
minnesota j'ai fait mon premier voyage
en avion le billet m'a coûté à cette
époque toutes mes économies et depuis ce
moment là il a fallu presque dix ans
avant que je puisse à nouveau envisager
un nouveau voyage lointain
mais ce voyage vers les états unis m'a
procuré une expérience unique car non
seulement j'ai pu passer du temps avec
mon ami mais j'ai aussi découvert ce
qu'on nomme le midwest et les zones
rurales qui dans ces années étaient
durement sinistré par la politique du
président reagan et où tout le monde
l'udf avec les moyens du bord pour la
survie je n'oublierai jamais comment
nous avons réparé le tracteur de la
ferme avec de la superpole car nous
avons simplement pas l'argent pour aller
dans un garage
mais reprenons ce tour d'horizon en nous
concentrant un peu plus sur ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans ma région
d'adoption la suisse romande et plus
spécifiquement général genève est une
région très international avec beaucoup
d'habitants qui viennent d'autres
parties du monde
aujourd'hui nous avons la chance de
pouvoir retourner vers nos régions
d'origine sans trop de problèmes et ceci
même pour des visites plus courte
durant la première phase de la ferme de
fermeture des frontières au début de la
pandémie nous avons vu à quel point
ceux-ci a frappé ces personnes qui ne
pouvaient plus retourner comme il avait
l'habitude ce qui a entraîné des
séparations de famille sur des longs -
et même aujourd'hui où les restrictions
liées à la pandémie ont été fortement
réduites une visite pour par exemple le
portugal
reste beaucoup plus compliqué en train
avec une durée de voyage approchant le
jour entier tandis qu'en avion le voyage
peut se faire en quelques heures
de plus il faut aussi regarder les
besoins de la genève internationale
ce qui implique notamment d'accueillir
près de 5000 ministre premier ministre
président et famille royale par an les
nombreux sièges des organisations
internationales et des organisations non
gouvernementales ne pourrait exister
sans un héros qui d'ailleurs a été
expressément fondé pour permettre les
débuts de la genève internationale avec
la soie cette société des nations en
finalement une région roman tournée vers
l'exportation a aussi besoin d'un
aéroport pour maintenir sa compétitivité
envers d'autres entreprises et d'autres
régions
rappelons-nous ceci voyager doit être
une possibilité ouverte offerte à tous
et pas comme dans la première moitié du
20e siècle limite à une classe de
dirigeants et de riches
alors revenons aux défis d'aujourd'hui
et plus spécifiquement le changement
climatique ce défi nous donne des
objectifs clairs nous devons suivant la
stratégie du conseil fédéral atteindre
en 2050 zéro émission de co2 est
naturellement l'aviation doit atteindre
le même objectif
mais pour bien gérer un tel objectif il
faut aussi savoir mettre les priorités
qui doivent être aussi basés sur la
contribution d'un secteur à la
problématique
comme illustration si nous prenons les
émissions de co2 l'aviation représente
mondialement moins de 5% des émissions
et en suisse où nous consommons plus
ceci est plutôt entre 5 et 10% mais il
reste que nous et ici je parle surtout
des responsables des différentes prises
dans le secteur d'aviation devons nous
engager et mettre en oeuvre toutes
les mesures nécessaires pour atteindre
cet objectif de neutralité d'émissions
co2 dans le délai nécessaire qui est
mais comme toujours il me semble
important de ne pas perdre de vue qui a
plusieurs qui a toujours plusieurs
chemins pour atteindre un objectif
est que chaque chemin à ses propres
avantages et coûts alors il me semble
important dans notre
quête de répondre aux défis du
changement climatique de se poser la
question comment choisir le meilleur
chemin atteindre cet objectif
alors voici ce que je me permets de
proposer de prendre comme critère pour
choisir ce chemin en se rappelant que
l'objectif final doit rester immuable la
neutralité en émissions co2 en 2050
premièrement il faut que nous nous
assurions que nous faisons un choix en
gardant autant les aspects écologiques
mais aussi sociaux et économiques
ceci dans un vrai esprit de
développement durable
deuxièmement il ne faut pas que nous
utilisons ce choix du chemin pour
imposer une vue politique ou sociétal
sur une autre sans vraie pesée
d'intérêts est un vrai débat
démocratique
troisièmement il faut que nous gardions
aussi en tête
que nous sommes dans un monde qui s'est
globalisée et de plus en plus
interconnecté ces dernières décennies je
suis convaincu que nous ne devons pas
bon non abandonner cette direction même
s'il est clair que nous devons la revoir
continuellement ceci est encore plus
important quand notre vie sociale
économique c'est beaucoup basé sur ces
évolutions
en regardant tout ceci comment
allons-nous alors répondre à ma question
du début si le voyage en avion est une
envie dépassé dans un monde luttant
contre le changement climatique
il me semble assez clair que tout ceci
nous incite à maintenir la liberté de
voyager et aussi en avion même si chacun
d'entre nous doit le voir dans une
optique de s'adapter à un mode de vie
plus en adéquation avec le défi du
changement climatique
finalement la réponse à la question
posée doit être que le voyage en avion
continue d'avoir son rôle à jouer dans
les moyens pour maintenir une liberté de
voyager mais que l'aviation doit montrer
comment elle va atteindre l'objectif de
2050 ne plus émettre du co2
en suisse depuis 2007 nous avons un
centre de compétences national de
recherche en art et en optique le
research center excellente forme et par
les grandes universités suisses ce
centre doit soutenir l'aviation suisse
avec l'exploration des innovations pour
continuer à améliorer son efficacité sa
sécurité et ses performances
environnementales
ce centre travaille en étroite
collaboration avec l'industrie
aéronautique et les autorités dans le
combat contre le changement climatique
l'aviation est appelé à contribuer à la
réduction des émissions de co2 et
atteindre l'objectif du conseil fédéral
de zéro émission co2 à ce titre
l'aviation research center suit sa lente
a lancé en 2020 le projet d'une feuille
de route de l'aviation suisse en
collaboration avec la société et complot
un groupe de travail composé de
représentants de suisse de la vie
l'association stella l'aviation
d'affaires des héros pour nationaux de
zurich genève et bâle de l'office
fédéral de l'aviation civile et de
l'office fédéral de l'environnement
ainsi que de les pf suric et de la haute
école spécialisée sur i was a accompagné
l'étude durant la phase finale du projet
easyjet a rejoint le groupe de travail
cette étude montre comment le transport
aérien au départ et vers la suisse peut
réduire réduire ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et son impact sur le
climat conformément aux objectifs de la
stratégie climatique à long terme du
conseil fédéral pour atteindre
l'objectif de zéro émission co2 sur la
base de cette étude suisse easyjet les
et vos pores de zurich genève bâle et
l'association suisse de l'aviation
d'affaires ont adopté la déclaration de
s'engager à atteindre le zéro émission
co2 en 2050
mais vous allez me demander comment
allons-nous faire ceci je vais partager
avec vous une vision un peu synthétique
qui se résument de la manière suivante
l'aviation suisse à l'intention de
mettre en oeuvre les quatre ensemble de
mesures suivantes
un remplacement progressif du kérosène
fossile par des combustibles biogen et
synthétique que nous appelons dans notre
jargon sustainable biofuels
qui réduiront les émissions co2 comparé
avec le kérosène de 80%
la promotion d'avions plus efficace et
ceci est pas que le long terme ça ça se
fait déjà aujourd'hui nous avons déjà
aujourd'hui des nouveaux avions sur nos
plateformes en suisse qui réduisent de
20 à 30% les émissions co2 et qui réduit
aussi le bruit qui est un autre fléau de
notre industrie de 40% et nous avons
déjà aujourd'hui par exemple à genève un
cinquième de toutes les mouvements qui
sont faits par ce type d'avion mais on
doit aussi prévoir à plus long terme
l'arrivée d'avions à nouvelle
motorisation soit-il électrique
hydrogène ou peut-être d'autres
technologies encore à développer et ceux
ci verra sa réalité des demies 30-35
une organisation d'un trafic aérien plus
économes en carburant au sol et en vol
déjà au sol on a beaucoup d'opérations
on a des véhicules qu'on doit décarbonés
c'est à dire les faire rouler en
électrique comme on le fait aussi à
genève mais on peut aussi améliorer en
servant les avions avec de l'électricité
du chaud et du froid qu'ils ont besoin
quand ils sont stationnés avec des
sources locales et à la base de
l'énergie renouvelable pour éviter
qu'ils utilisent le réacteur pour
générer ça
et finalement on peut aussi nettement
améliorer les approches et les les
décollages et le volant nerfs pour
justement réduire l'utilisation de ou de
production de carburants est de kérosène
est de co2 et finalement l'utilisation
d'instruments économiques compensation
volontaire du co2 participation à des
échanges de marché de co2 korcia qui est
le programme de l'aviation mondiale pour
arrêter l'augmentation des émissions co2
comme solution provisoire parce que
c'est que au premier temps après ça doit
être remplacé par les autres mesures que
je viens de donner ainsi que des projets
de suppression de carbone c'est à dire
l'extraction du co2 de l'air pour
réduire les émissions restantes et 7 co2
qui était extrait peut justement être
utilisé comme matière de base pour créer
des carburants synthétiques
alors en conclusion je reviens à ma
question le voyage en avion une envie de
passer je voudrais dire non c'est une
liberté que nous avons beaucoup
travaillé pour l'acquérir pour pouvoir
voir nos amis dans d'autres pays nos
familles dans d'autres pays deux allées
découvrir d'autres cultures d'avoir une
vie comme ça mais l'industrie d'aviation
et vous consommateurs on doit se mettre
ensemble pour justement rendre ce type
de voyage sans impact sur le climat en
réduisant à zéro les émissions co2 et
c'est un engagement de l'aviation civile
merci
[Applaudissements]